hi everyone I am M and welcome to this
fantastic video on how to become an AI
engineer in
2024 before we begin with the video if
you enjoy watching these kind of videos
and find them interesting then subscribe
to our YouTube channel as we bring the
best videos for you da also hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
Simply so let's get started in the
dynamic land scape of artificial
intelligence the role of an a engineer
has emerged as a critical sort after
position insufficient planning
unsuitable architecture and an inability
to scale our common causes of failure in
AI projects these AI professionals
bridge the gap between Cutting Edge AI
Technologies and real world business
challenges crafting innovative solutions
that drive success organizations are
always on the lookout for AI Engineers
to Aid in the formulation of
architectural Str strategy the
development of operations and the
identification of tools and features so
in this video we will discuss what it
takes to become an AI engineer their
duties how much they earn and how they
worry from those of an AI solution
architect so before we move on to who is
an AI engineer if you are an aspiring Ai
and machine learning engineer then
there's no better time to train yourself
in the exciting field of artificial
intelligence if you're looking for a
course that covers everything from the
fundamental to advanc techniques then
accelerate your career in Ai and machine
learning with a comprehensive
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and machine learning course delivered in
collaboration with the per University
and IBM learn in demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
gbt and many more you'll also receive a
prestigious certificate and ask me
anything s by IBM with five capston in
different domains using real data sets
you will of course gain practical
experience master classes by PD faculty
and IBM experts inure topnotch education
and simply learns job assist helps you
get noticed by the leading companies so
this program covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural network computer vision Gan caras
tensorflow and many more such skills
admission to this post-graduate
programing Ai and machine learning
requires a bachelor's degree with an
average of 50% or higher marks along
with basic understanding of programming
Concepts and Mathematics and candidates
with two plus years of work experience
are preferred to enroll in this program
so enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunities the link
is mentioned in the description box
below so without any further delay let's
see who is an AI engineer an AI engineer
constructs AI models employing machine
learning algorithms and deep learning
neural networks to extract business
insights these insights in turn inform
organizational decisions that impact the
entire company AI Engineers develop
diverse AI applications including
contextual advertising using sentiment
analysis visual identification or
perception and language translation the
next section of AI engineer road map
focuses on AI Engineers versus AI
solution architect AI Engineers uses
machine learning and neural networks for
bu business AI models they require
skills in software engineering data
science and programming AI Architects
create Advanced AI infrastructure
emphasizing with customer needs to
provide Solutions every AI focused
Enterprise needs an architect skilled in
data analysis AI Frameworks and
infrastructure next up we have the roles
and responsibilities of an AI engineer
as an AI engineer or a machine learning
engineer you need to perform certain
tasks such as develop test and deploy AI
models through programming algorithms
like random Forest logistic regression
linear regression and so on so these
responsibilities include convert the
machine learning models into application
program interfaces or API so that other
applications can use it build AI models
from scratch and help the different
components of the organization automate
the infrastructure that the data science
team uses set up and manage AI
development and product infrastructure
and lastly be a good team player as
coordinating with others is a must
because AI may be used in such a wide
variety of contexts and displayed in so
many different ways Architects or
Engineers of AI systems need to possess
a diversified set of skills including
technical skills the number one is
programming skills the first skill
required to become an AI engineer is
programming to become well versed in AI
it's crucial to learn programming
languages such as python R Java and C++
to build an Implement model models next
up is linear algebra probability and
statistics to understand and Implement
different AI models such as hidden Marco
models knive Bas you must have detailed
knowledge of linear algebra probability
and of course statistics the next is
spark and Big Data Technologies AI
Engineers work with large volumes of
data such as streaming or real-time
production level data in terabytes or
even petabytes along with the pespa one
can also use other Big Data Technologies
such as Hadoop Cassandra and mongod next
up we have algorithms and Frameworks
understanding how machine learning
algorithms like linear regression KNN
knife Bas support Vector machine and
others work will help you easily
Implement machine learning models
technical expertise is necessary but
it's not enough you need to be well
wored in certain soft skills including
communication skills there's a broad
range of people with different levels of
competence that artificial intelligence
Engineers have to talk domain expertise
engineers in the field of machine
learning must recognize both the demands
of the company and the sorts of
obstacles their designs are addressing
in order to create self-running programs
and optimize Solutions utilized by
organizations and customers the next
soft skill is time management engineers
in the field of artificial intelligence
must balance the needs of several
stakeholders with the need to do
research organize and plan projects
create software and thoroughly tested
the last but not the least is teamwork
members of the AI and it communities
often collaborate with one another the
ability to operate successfully and
productively in a team is a valuable
skill to have moving forward let's see
the salary of an AI engineer there's a
possibility that the salary will worry
depending on the company as well as the
level of knowledge and experience that
you bring with yourself so top companies
like Samsung Turing Accenture and many
more are hiring air engineers in the
United States according to glaso the
average salary of an air engineer in the
United States goes around
$135,000 annually moving on to India the
demand for AI engineers in India has CAU
the attention of major industry players
with renowned companies such as
springworks IBM Seamans and others are
actively seeking to add these
professionals to their teams according
to glaso the national average salary for
an engineer is rupees 11 lakhs perom in
India with additional cash compensation
so in conclusion embracing AI isn't just
a choice it's a strategic decision that
can reshape how organization approaches
machine learning so accelerate your
career in AI in machine learning with a
comprehensive professional certificate
course in artificial intelligence and
machine learning this machine learning
course will equip you with highly coet
skills in machine learning deep learning
natural language processing generative
AI prompt engineering chat gbt and much
more through live classes by industry
experts master classes from IIT Kor
faculty and Hands-On projects you will
stay ahead in the field of artificial
intelligence this Ai and machine
learning course covers Concepts like
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing reinforcement
learning computer vision explainable AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and much
more so for admission to this artificial
intelligence course candidate should
have a bachelor's degree with an average
of 50% or marks prior knowledge or
experience in programming and
Mathematics and candidates with two plus
years of work experience are preferred
to enroll in this program send roll now
and unlock exciting Ai and machine
learning opportunities join now the
seats are filling fast the course link
is mentioned in the description box
below and with that we have come to the
end of this video on how to become an AI
engineer in 2024 I hope you found it
valuable and entertaining so please ask
any questions about the topics covered
in this video and in the comment section
below and our team of experts will help
you in addressing your problems as soon
as possible so thank you so much for
being here we'll see you next time until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
Simply Le staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here